donc après l'iut j'ai décidé de prendre
mon niveau d'anglais en main qui était
plutôt médiocre et donc de partir en
irlande pour six mois de remise à niveau
et donc je me souviens de mon arrivée à
dublin
j'étais hébergé dans une famille
d'accueil et donc il fallait que j'aille
chez eux et donc j'étais dans cette
grande ville avec mes deux grosses
valises et donc elle m'avait expliqué
fallait que je prenne un bus
il habitait dans dublin 24 donc j'en
avais pour à peu près une heure et
ensuite elle venait me chercher l'arrêt
de bus donc j'ai cherché le but ça a été
compliqué j'ai fini par le trouver et
donc j'étais dans le bus
toujours avec mes grosses valises et
j'étais en panique totale
je me demandais où j'allais je savais
pas si j'allais être sympa si j'allais
comprendre comment elle allait être
enfin bon voilà leur s'est passé je suis
arrivé à l'arrêt de bus hélas le cliché
donc vous savez toutes les petites
maisons en anglaise les unes à côté des
autres et toujours en stress à me dire
oh là là mais comment ça va être
et puis j'étais sur un trottoir je
savais pas où j'étais enfin bon elle a
fini par arriver
elle était très sympa mais alors elle
arrêtait pas de parler à ouidah blinoise
en france donc moi j'étais assis dans la
voiture j'étais là ok ok yes yes
et puis donc elle a commencé à me
raconter une histoire elle propose une
petite fille donc ça va être important
j'ai pas compris j'ai juste compris que
c'était à propos d'une petite fille et
que c'était important et donc elle me
dit isda look & feel you do you mind moi
j'étais là ok non ok no problem hockey
et donc on arrive chez eux
je sors de la voiture je prends mes
grosses valises bond et jallet j'étais
un petit peu moins stressé je rentre
dans la maison et là leurs quatre
enfants se jettent à mon cou aïe pauline
elle aurait l'eau
et moi j'étais là au caire y salue
hockey est donc là leur père arrive mais
moi avec mon pauvre anglais tout
fièrement je tends la main et jeudi
nice to meet you et là il arrive il me
prend dans ses bras
paulina istc yogan round trip
et donc voilà je comprends rien je me
disais me manquer où je suis bon ils
sont sympas et là une petite fille est
arrivée et en fait c'était une petite
fille espagnols qu'ils hébergeaient en
même temps et il n'avait pas le droit
d'héberger d'autres étudiants en même
temps qu'elle donc il avait prétendu que
j'étais une amie de la famille et que je
venais en vacances chez eux
donc elle m'avait demandé de jouer le
jeu super le premier jour donc voilà
c'est comme ça que ma ville expats a
commencé finalement je ne suis pas resté
six mois mais je suis resté quatre ans à
dublin dont pendant ces quatre années
j'ai vécu des choses extraordinaires et
je voulais partager avec vous certaines
de ses expériences
donc je pourrais vous parler des mille
et une raisons de s'expatrier
mais j'ai choisi de vous parler de trois
raisons particulières donc après mon
séjour en famille d'accueil
j'ai trouver une colocation dans le
centre ville avec quatre brésiliens et
une italienne
là c'était génial on échangeait sur
notre musique sur nos sur nos cultures
sur nos façons de manger on se demandait
comment tu dis ça en portugais et
comment tu dis ça en français et en
italien
chacun notre tour on se faisait une
spécialité de chez nous donc moi je leur
ai fait une tartiflette et c'était
vraiment super ensuite j'ai partagé ma
chambre avec une ukrainienne pendant
neuf mois
donc à nouveau c'était génial elle me
raconter plein d'histoires sur son pays
on a eu un partage de haut niveau de
notre culture des échanges c'est
vraiment la france l'ukraine c'est
vraiment différent c'était vraiment
intéressant
elle en ukraine elle était danseuse et
elle avait abandonné son rêve de devenir
professionnel en partant l'étranger et
donc voilà je vais pas vous parler de
tous mes colocs puisque j'en ai eu plus
de 20 pendant quatre ans mais c était
vraiment des personnes formidables
donc après ma remise en niveau d'anglais
j'ai travaillé dans un café donc à
nouveau donc j'ai travaillé avec une
polonaise une française
un romain et une américaine et ensuite
donc ma troisième année j'ai continué
j'ai repris mes études en bachelor est
donc cette fois à nouveau plein de
rencontres notamment une maman sud
africaine qui avait 36 ans une petite
fille de 6 ans et qui reprenait ses
études et elle était vraiment admirable
parce que j étais vraiment dédié et
c'était vraiment une personne
intéressante
ensuite en parallèle de mon bachelor
j'ai travaillé dans un restaurant
italien donc j'avais rencontré quelques
italiens qui travaillait là bas pendant
l'été et il m'avait intégré à leur
communauté et c'était vraiment super
c'était c'était vraiment comme une
famille pour moi et c'est ce qui a fait
que je me suis senti bien à cette
période à dublin et donc mes deux
dernières années en irlande j'ai
travaillé dans des entreprises
américaines qui ont leur siège social
basé à dublin donc à nouveau j'ai
travaillé avec des irlandais les
américains des indiens des allemands des
italiens est donc à nouveau des
rencontres enrichissantes d'un point de
vue personnel mais également
professionnelle les codes ne sont pas
les mêmes suivant le pays suivant les
nationalités donc c'était un challenge
il fallait s'adapter
donc au final pour eux toutes ces
rencontres c'est ça a été vraiment des
rencontres atypiques qui m'ont enrichi
il ya des personnes que j'ai rencontrées
la base c'est devenu vraiment des vrais
amis
finalement nous avions un point en
commun c'était le fait qu'on était
étranger dans un même pays et ça crée
des liens qui sont particuliers
donc pour moi c'est ça la première
richesse ce sont les rencontres donc
pour continuer ensuite avec les
rencontres
je vous racontais trois histoires qui
m'ont marqué la première histoire donc
c'est l'histoire de d'un de mes
collègues au café dans lequel j'ai
travaillé donc il avait vécu en italie
parfaite il parlait pardon parfaitement
italien et donc il était chef au sein du
café donc c'était las des cakes comme
ils disent ils étaient mariés ils
avaient deux ils avaient des enfants il
habitait dans une petite maison à dublin
il était super professionnel très sympa
toujours une petite blague à faire et
puis un jour en discutant avec ma
collègue française el mehdi en fait
qu'il ait pas italien mais qui les
roumains et qu'en fait il dit qu'il est
italien car elle a honte d'être de dire
qu'il est romain et je me souviens
penser mais pourquoi avoir honte
puisqu'il avait tout d'une personne
respectable peu importe d'où ils
venaient ensuite la deuxième histoire
c'est l'histoire d'une amie qui venait
d'un pays hors union européenne et qui
au fil des mois et au fil des jours on
voyait son visa expiré et donc il
fallait qu'elle trouve une solution pour
rester donc elle avait plusieurs choix
le premier bain
bon le premier c'était de rentrer mais
du coup c'était hors question puisque
les conditions étaient trop compliqué le
deuxième c'était de reprendre les études
mais elle en avait fait déjà beaucoup et
elle avait plus envie et la troisième
finalement c'était de ce2 d'obtenir un
visa par son employeur
ce qui aurait dû normalement se passe et
qui finalement n'a pas marché et donc
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle a payé un
ami à elle européens pour se marier
donc il vivait comme un couple ordinaire
il dit habiter ensemble ils dormaient
ensemble ils vivaient ensemble et je me
souviens l ai reçu beaucoup de jugement
par rapport à cette décision mais
finalement comment pouvons-nous savoir
ce que nous aurions fait si nous avions
été dans la situation
et la troisième histoire c'est
l'histoire d'une de mes colocataires
française d'origine ivoirienne
donc elle m'a raconté un jour son
arrivée en france pour le moins imprévue
donc tous les ans avec sa famille il
venait passer trois semaines à paris en
vacances c'était leur rituel est donc un
été quand elle avait 7 ans ils sont
venus donc ses parents sa soeur son
frère et ce même été la guerre civile a
éclaté en côte d'ivoire et elle n'est
jamais rentrée
imaginez vous partez avec une petite
valise pour trois semaines au retour
vous retrouvez votre famille vos amis
vos affaires et finalement ou le
reverrai jamais elle à bientôt 30 ans
elle n'est jamais retourné en côte
d'ivoire pourquoi je vous raconte ses
histoires parce que c'est face à ces
personnes par face à leurs histoires
personnelles à leur vécu que j'ai su
remettre en cause des idées des préjugés
que j'aurais pu avoir avant finalement
ce que nous vivons depuis que nous
sommes enfant est différent d'une
personne à l'autre d'un pays à l'autre
et j'ai rencontré des personnes qui ont
pu avoir un parent alcoolique qui ont pu
se faire virer de chez eux ou bien même
tombé dans la drogue et finalement qui
sommes nous pour juger donc grandissant
avec les idées que nos parents nous
inculque la société ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire ses parts et voyager découvrir
et faites vous votre propre avis
l'expatriation vous permettra de vous
ouvrir l'esprit elle vous mettra dans
face à ces personnes qui vous
apporteront un regard différent lorsque
vous partez soyez prêt à ouvrir votre
esprit et à faire tomber vos préjugés
surtout la troisième chose dont je
voulais vous parler aujourd'hui c'est la
confiance en soi
la vie d'expatrié peut parfois vous
mettre dans des situations à l'épreuve
et s'avancer situation vous permettront
de vous découvrir la vie des stades
c'est pas toujours aussi sans plus donc
pour ma part à partir de ma troisième
année j'ai parfois commencé à ressentir
un sentiment de solitude
ma famille me manquait mais les amis
restés en france et finalement je me dis
que je préfère voir le côté positif le
côté positif c'est que la solitude c'est
un sentiment qui est difficile à vivre
qui est difficile à accepter mais c'est
un sentiment que vous devez accueillir à
bras ouverts car elle vous apprendra
énormément de choses sur vous pendant
mes deux dernières années
maintenant avec un an de recul je me
rends compte que c'est à cette période
que j'ai commencé à faire plein de
nouvelles choses j'allais au cinéma deux
à trois fois par semaine je me suis
intéressé à l'art de plus en plus j'ai
acheté une guitare j'ai pris des cours
d'espagnol
j'ai revendu la guitare un an après et
j'avais plus de temps à me consacrer et
donc j'avais plus de temps pour
découvrir finalement qui j'étais et ce
que j'aimais d'ailleurs vous noterez que
toutes ces activités sont des activités
qui se font au chaud à l'abri de la
pluie
chose non-négligeable en irlande et donc
au fur et à mesure du temps j'ai
commencé à me sentir de plus en plus
seul et mes amis partent est de plus en
plus et ça m'a permis finalement de me
poser et de découvrir de nouvelles
activités qui me passionne et de
découvrir ce que je recherchais d'un
point de vue professionnel
mais d'un point de vue également
personnelle et donc ça fait maintenant
un an que je suis rentré en france et
donc quand je suis rentré l'année
dernière j'avais pas vraiment de projet
fixe j'ai commencé à postuler à quelques
oeuvres d'emplois mais il n'y avait rien
qui ment valait plus que ça
et donc en début 2010 8 en irlande
j'avais passé un certificat pour
enseigner l'anglais
si un jour j'avais un projet
d'enseignement en france ou même
ailleurs
si ge envisageait de partir ailleurs et
donc je me suis dit bon allez pourquoi
pas c'est maintenant et donc je me suis
lancé et je me suis mis à mon compte et
je fais de la formation en anglais pour
les professionnels je pense que sur
toute cette année en france dans toute
ma vie j'ai jamais eu autant de projets
qui se sont mis en place d'un point de
vue professionnel mais également d'un
point de vue personnel et je pense que
si ça s'est passé comme ça c'est parce
que quand je suis rentré je savait qui
j'étais je savais ce que je recherchais
à ce moment je savais ce que je voulais
et je suis donc prendre les bonnes
décisions
j'avais donc pris plus confiance en moi
finalement qu'est-ce qui a déclenché
tout cela c'était mon envie d'avoir un
meilleur niveau en anglais une fois que
j'avais un bon niveau en anglais ça m'a
donné une ouverture sur un monde que je
n'avais pas accès en parlant seulement
français je suis persuadé que
l'expérience serait la même dans un
autre pays avec une autre langue
n'ayez pas peur de partir car la
récompense n'est pas mesurable
vous reviendrez changer vous aurez vécu
des choses uniques
vous avez rencontré des personnes qui
vous aura apporté un regard différent
sur le monde
pendant ces quatre années l'ouverture
d'esprit que j'ai acquise grâce à la
découverte de l'inconnu et à la grâce à
la découverte de moi-même et grâce aux
rencontres sont les plus belles
richesses de l'expert de l'expatriation
que j'ai vécu alors pourquoi ne pas
tenter l'expérience vous même
[Applaudissements]